STEWART BRAND: So on the one hand, you've got the sort of top of the investment level
perspective on art: this incredibly
expensive and rather magnificent museum
going in. I was an artist in the Lower East Side of
New York back in the day and the people
I was hanging out were of course on the
Lower East Side because that's where it was
cheap to live. And everything was on the
"just getting by" level. And so I assume
that's going on with many young ambitious
artists in Hong Kong and elsewhere. And
then that overlaps into, in a sense, art is
always rebellion, anyway. You're always
rebelling against the standard art of
before, you're rebelling against "The Man,"
whoever that institution is seen as. And protesters I know in the United States are in awe of
the protesters in Hong Kong right now,
who seem to have more creative
techniques, and more creative artistry in
a way in their protests. That's pretty
interesting and bottom-up kind of
creativity. What's your perspective on that?
SUHANYA RAFFEL: It's very interesting to watch the
the visual language that's being applied
now in Hong Kong. Primarily, of course,
it's a tool for communication; it has
nothing to do with the museum per se. But as
a museum, we are very interested in that
as a visual culture form. The protesters
use the this emblem to describe
themselves: they talk about
themselves as being like water. So they
will flow. They're free-flowing. They're
leaderless. They're spontaneous. And so a
lot of the material
that's been that's taking place in terms
of protest is digital. And it's a
digital form as a communication tool.
And all of it is unauthored at this point. They do not want to have a single author.
It's not in their interest to do so. Our teams are very interested, we're out
documenting. We have archives. And so we
can document, we are doing that. And
researching. How or when and if it enters
the collection, it has to go through the
usual museum mechanism and process of
thinking and looking and seeking rights:
Who owns these things? And perhaps they
are not to be owned, and that's fine. But
then it exists in other kinds of ways. So
it's a very very interesting
phenomena this time. Unlike say, much, much
earlier periods of protest art, which had
very clear activist expressions. In the U.S. there
are the Guerrilla Girls and there are
whole portfolios of prints and so on
that are very clearly authored and
there for distribution. This is a very
different mechanism that that's taking
place in Hong Kong. And the digital tool
is phenomenal.